Currently, the user has no way of
knowing they've entered a location that
our server can not handle.
In fact, our source code is also
blissfully unaware of this case.
We'll fix that.
We'll have to add a new location status.
Location status invalid.
But how do we know that that
location is unknown to the server?
It turns out that with each transaction,
the Open Weather Map API returns
a code in JSON similar to HTTP codes.
For success it returns 200,
if the location isn't found it returns
a 404 error, location not found.
So if we see a 404 error we know that
the user has entered something that
the server doesn't understand.
Great, we can modify the code and
get weather data from JSON
to understand this code.
Then we can set the location
status to the invalid state,
when this response is detected.